el presidente Gabriel Boris cumplió este
viernes con una de sus más antiguas y
también polémicas
promesas de campaña al finalmente
indultó a 12
personas condenadas por
delitos vinculados al estallido social
en una decisión muy polémica sobre todo
por los sectores de la derecha del país
que han criticado la medida como
inaceptable y preocupante y han tomado
medidas como retirarse de un acuerdo de
seguridad que se estaba negociando entre
todos los partidos del país en este
momento además también se amenaza con
poder llegar incluso a solicitar la
dimisión de la ministra de Justicia o
llegar incluso a acusaciones
constitucionales fue una medida por otro
lado acogida de forma muy favorable por
la asociación Nacional de presos de la
revuelta por los familiares que venían
luchando desde hace bastantes meses para
que el presidente Gabriel boric
cumpliera esta medida que ha tratado de
hacer A través de una ley en el congreso
en una de sus primeras tomas de
decisiones en cuanto llegó a la moneda
pero esta ley no prosperó en el congreso
no tuvo los votos necesarios para lograr
la amnistía de una gran parte de todas
las personas envueltas en delitos o en
condenas durante el estallido social al
no hacerlo así se ha recurrido al
indulto que es una facultad del
presidente establecida por una ley que
así lo Norma y se han estudiado caso a
caso para ir dando lo que serían los
primeros de estos 12 indultos a los que
se añade el de Jorge matte Luna y que
podrían ir ampliándose en próximos meses